[音楽]
ブービーこんにちはーフロスですアフ
ロマンとよく間違えられるんですがアフロ
とロマンスでアフロまーすっと言います
肩書は体験クリエイターと名乗ってます
体験くれたとはアイディアと実現力で
新しい体験を作るという活動です
例えばパワーパーというイベントがあり
ます
泡パーティーの略なんですが
あまり塗れる体験型の音楽イベントです
これ不思議なんですけど
泡にまみれると男性でも女性でも年齢も
関係なく皆何かこう楽しくなっちゃう
みたいな
お祝いの時にビールかけとか
あとはなんかこうトマト祭りとかタイの
水かけ祭りとかありますけどああいうなん
かこう塗れる体験っていうのはなんかこう
非日常な気持ちになっちゃって
こう自分の殻を破りいるみたいなそういう
体験なのかなと思っていますそして2つ目
すら is the city
こちらはは300メーターのウォーター
スライダーを道路に弾いてそこを滑ると
いう体験型イベントになりますもともと
アメリカのソルトリークでやっていたもの
があってそれを僕は youtube で
八景して
でこれはめっちゃ楽しそうなと思って連絡
してそれで日本で開催しましたみて
くださいこの映像おなんかわかんないけど
楽しそうそんな感じません
その感覚大事なんでぜひ覚えておいて
ください
そして型バー from さがこちらは
佐賀県の有明海の干潟の方ですねこれ海の
泥なんですけどこれの上澄みのクリーミー
な部分を4頭を持ってきてそれを東京の
青山でドローンに疲れるばにしたという
企画ですなんかだんだんと僕が好きそうな
感覚がわかってきたのかなと思うんですが
最後に桜散るバーヴァイスさがこちらは
120万枚の花びらに埋もれるバーっと
いうのを作りました
もうまあこれ見た目からしてこうつくしー
ですよね
ちなみにこれ桜散るバーのチルノ部分は
英語で言うチルアウトと桜の花びらが
舞い散る
この2つのダブルみー
になっていますこんな感じで50種類以上
僕は今まで体験型の企画をどんどんやって
きたんですが
そんな中で結構聞かれることがあります
なんでそんな面白いことをやれるんですか
と
まぁこれって2つの側面があるかなと思っ
ています
一つはなんでそんなアイデアが思いつくの
か
もう一つはなんでそんなことが実現できる
のか
このアイディアと実現という部分は冒頭お
話しした体験クリエイターの根幹にも
つながる部分で僕もすごく大事にしている
要素なんですけど特に僕がまあ他と比べて
強いかなと思うのは実現の部分です
例えばアワパワー
イビザ島の名物パーティーから来ています
し
スライザシティは先ほど言ったように
アメリカのソルトレークでやられていた
ものを日本にローカライズしたわけです僕
は完全におりそれで考えたということでは
なくこれを日本で実現したというところに
すごく価値があることですね例えばその
後半の2つに関しては僕のアイディアには
なるんですが
アイディアというものはそもそも経験の中
で結構磨かれる部分が大きいなと思ってい
ます最初から何がすごいことができると
いう人やっぱりいないわけです何かを作っ
て行く中で色々アイディアとかセンスが
磨かれていってねまあすごいアイディアと
かも出るになったりするとそういう意味で
アイディアと地図件どっちが先か止めたら
実は実現が先であるということは僕は思っ
ていて今日はそんな中で理屈じゃないもの
を実現させる方法についてお話ししたいな
と思っています
まず最初に来ないことですけどあなたが
やりたいことって
何でしょう
漫画家期待でもいいですし
ゲーム作りたいてもいいですし
旅に出たいでもいいです
やりたいことなんて言えば人それぞれなの
で何でもいいからちょっと六壁てみて
ください
何かしら思い浮かぶと思います
次になんでそれをやりたいと思ったんです
かって聞かれたらどうでしょうかまあ
即答できる人もいればちょっと考えちゃう
って人もいると思います
例えば
やったことによって喜ぶ人の笑顔が見たい
からとかもあるでしょうし
世の中をより良くするためという人もいる
でしょ
それはまぁ全部別に間違ってはいないと
思いますし素晴らしいことだと思います
でもここでちょっとあの
立ち止まってほしいのは
でもさっきやりたいことを思い浮かべる
ときにその理由から考えていたかなって
いうことなんです実は純粋にそれがやり
たかっただけなんじゃないかみたいなやり
たいから好きだから
一見なんかあのまあとても簡単なことに
聞こえるんですが
でもシンプルだからこそするアップすごい
ピアなと思っていて
それがあなたが持っている感性だし個性な
んだなと思っていますそしてまあ関西とか
個性っていうのはまあ一人それぞれ違うの
でお互い理解できなかったりする
なのでなんでそういう風に思ったんで
すかっとかまぁ聞かれてしまうとやっぱり
相手が理解できる理屈をやっぱり探して
しまうんですねここで押さえておきたいの
は
やりたいっていう気持ちはリックスじゃ
ない部分があるということです
説明できるものもあるしできないものも
ある
これってまあ
当たり前っちゃ当たり前なんですけどでも
結構何かを作るっていうことになった時に
結構見失いがちなことだなぁと思ってい
ますついつい最初から理屈から考えていく
と
理屈上正しいものができるんだけど何か心
に響かないなみたいな物ができたりするん
ですポー等にお見せしたまあいろんな企画
がありましたけどそれを見たときになんか
楽しそうだなってまあ思ってくれた方は
その感覚こそがとても大事なんです
じゃあそれだけで実現できるかというと
やっぱりできませんじゃあどうすればいい
のか
ここでちょっと経験がお話させて頂きたい
と思いますスライ the city
本当に大変なイベントだったんですよ特に
大変だったのは場所がない問題ですねまー
すライザーシティの動画をオーバー見て
もらうとこういう人がキュンキュンと小道
をすべていう訳ですけどこれってどういう
仕組みで滑っているかってわかりますかね
僕は何かこの動画を見たときになんか
きっと画期的なすごいシステムがあるん
だろうなって思ったんですよそれですぐ
連絡してすぐライセンスを取ったんです
けどその後にこう話していたらすごいこと
に気づいたんですよあれはただの坂道だっ
たっていう様は坂道に
ビニールを敷いて水を流しているだけなん
ですねじゃあ次に問題になっていうのは
何かというとつまりこのイベントを開催
するためには300メーターの直線の巨大
な道路封鎖しないといけないということが
わかった多いです道路封鎖するということ
はとても大変なことをなんですね特に日本
だとまずそもそもアメリカに比べたら道が
狭いですし
直線もまあ少ないですよね結構やっぱり
曲がってたりもするとかつその大きな道路
は行政とか服にとかそういうところが管理
されているのでそこの許可も当然得ないと
いけないと担当者に
僕はこういう話を持ってるわけですよこの
スライザシティというすごい巨大な
スライダーを引きたいからこの4車線の
道路を
48時間封鎖させてほしい
やばいんお願いですねこれね
通るのかと
でもあきらめずにスライドしてみよさを
説いているわけですよ
そんな時に担当者に言われた一言があって
よく覚えてるんですけど
スライダーが楽しいよくわかりました
ちなみにこれって有名ちゃダメなんですか
って言われたんですよ
そのときに僕はもう規模にガツンときた
わけですよ
確かに良いみたいなトレくらい頭になかっ
たんですよね巨大なその間が好きだったら
遊園地に行けばいいかもしれない new
h やればいいかもしれないでも同時に
思うわけですよそれだとつまんないじゃん
と僕がやりたいのは道でスライダーを
滑らしたんだと
遊園地になったら普通じゃないかとそれー
は嫌だとでこれっても理由がないというか
もう自分の中のなんかも子供と一緒で嫌な
んですよ
道が絶対面白いですよ
でここでまぁチームとして一生懸命
いろいろ調べましたを調べていく中で一つ
見つけたのが
国交省が道をコミュニティスペースとして
復権したいとこういう話があったんですね
例えばお祭りを思い浮かべてもらったら
いいんですけど
お祭りってだいたい以降道を封鎖している
わけですね了方にごで店が出て
で a神輿を担いだりしてでこの道で
みんな校交流するわけですだから道は
もともとそういう機能があったんですが
それが今近代になって
車が走っていて忘れ去られているわけです
でイベントで使いたいってなってもそんな
のできるわけないでしょっていう前提に
なってしまうのですがそれを復権したいと
これは僕すごいいい話だなと思って辛いザ
シティの話をするときにもこの道としての
コミュニティスペースのホッケーをしたい
とそういう話も合わせてしましたそしたら
担当者はなるほどと言って実に至ったわけ
です
これだかね色々子を聞いていると思うこと
があるかもしれません
理由が変わっていいんじゃないみたいな
でもこれはあの僕は順番の問題だと思って
ますまず自分の本当にやりたいことを
捉えるためには理屈じゃない感覚っていう
のはとても大事なんですね例えばその道路
を巨大スライダーで据えるのは超楽しいと
かじゃあこれが遊園地になった時には何か
やりたいこと違うみたいな
なんかその何かっていうところって
とっても大事なんですよ
その上でそれを実現するためにはみんなが
納得する必要がありますよね
そこにやっぱりみんなが納得する理屈が
必要になってくる
で先ほどの話といえば道のコミュニティ
スペースとしての復権という話になって
いるわけです
ここでまぁちょっと注意したのは何がやり
たいこのために嘘をつけばいいということ
ではないんです
僕は心からその視点が素晴らしいなと思っ
たんです
これはやりたいことを実現させていく過程
の中で調べていくと新しい発見というもの
が必ずあるんですね
で新しい事を知っていいと思ったらそれを
取り入れる増やすつまりやりたいっていう
理由は1個じゃなくていいんですよ
やりたい理由は
やっていく中で変化もするし笛もすると
喜ぶ笑顔が見たいからっていうことこれは
僕もすごく共感することであの
まああんなイベントをじゃあ買った一人で
無盡頭であっても全然面白くはないわけ
ですよ
やっていく中でこうきた人たちがすごく
喜んでくれるそれがやっぱりなんか嬉しい
しやりがいにつながっていく
ただなんでこの曲を初めてのかといったら
自分がやりたかったからっていうことなん
ですねそこをちゃんと持つことで売れない
軸になっていくということです
また行ってみてわかるということも
たくさんあります
例えば雨パあれはもう僕が個人的に絶対
やったら面白いという直感のもと始めまし
たで行った結果どうなったかというと
クラブにこんな人達がたくさん来るように
なったんですね
日本に特にあの強ことなんですけどクラブ
に行くのに少しハードルが結構あるんです
よ
でまたそんな人たちも比べに来たらもう
みんな楽しくなっちゃうみたいな
それのきっかけづくりとしてあぁパーカー
機能しているということに来た人たちの声
を聞いて初めて知ったんですね
これもあのクラブが好きな僕としては一つ
やりがいだったりするんですが
クラブシーンを広げるために arpa を
始めたわけではないこの順番っていうのは
あのとても大事だなと思っていますこれは
経験則として僕を持っているんですが良い
企画っていうのは最初に狙うっていなかっ
たような思わぬ副作用みたいな事が起こる
んです
その副作用があの結構いいこともたくさん
あってそれが後々やりがいになっていくと
いうこともあります
今日伝えたかったこと理屈じゃないものを
実現させる方法
最後にまとめてお伝えしたいと思います
まず理屈じゃない感覚を大事にすること
自分のなかの感性や個性
直感とかときめきとかそういうものを大事
にしてください
そこからスタートすると自分のブレない軸
ができます
そして実現するために皆が納得する新たな
理由を探しましょう
やる理由っていうのは一つじゃなくていい
んです
そして実現した結果初めて見えるものも
たくさんあります
みんなが巻き込まれていくハッピーな副
作用を探すそして結果としてやりたいから
やりがいになっていく
今自分の中にやりたいを持っている人や
何かを実現したい人の参考になれば幸い
です
ありがとうございました